autos die selbst fahren beibringt kriegs
fahrzeuge die sich ihre ziele
automatisiert suchen oder software die
krebstumore identifiziert künstliche
intelligenz bringt nicht nur fortschritt
mit sicht sondern eben auch nachteile
forscher warnen eindringlich die ki ist
auf dem weg eine große gefahr für uns
menschen zu werden denn wer diejenigen
entscheidungen der krise über leben und
tod entscheiden kann kein mensch
nachvollziehen welche folgenschweren
konsequenzen verfahren kann und was
forscherteam weltweit dafür tun um eine
lösung für die brisante problem zu
finden erfahrt ihr jetzt im krieg zum
reifen wirklich willkommen
wir hatten ja schon öfter über k wie
berichtet ihr jetzt in zusammenarbeit
mit der zeitschrift technology review
unser schwerpunkt zum thema und am ende
gibt es noch eine grafische ausgabe der
zeitschrift als bleibt dran 2016 hatte
eine amerikanische chip-hersteller
nvidia tatsächlich das unvorstellbare
erstmalig auf den straßen von new jersey
getestet auch wenn es auf den ersten
blick aus wie ein ganz normales selbst
fahren das auto war rechtlich eine große
sensation denn das auto fuhr zwar
alleine
doch es folgte ganz und gar nicht den
anweisungen eines entwicklers es fuhr
wächst ständig und das habe sich das
auto tatsächlich auch selbst beigebracht
und zwar indem es zuvor menschen beim
autofahren beobachtet habe das klingt
echt ziemlich abgefahren um wahr zu sein
und nein es ist nicht das drehbuch für
einen science fiction film die forschung
in diesem bereich ist verdächtig so weit
die learning ist der fachbegriff und
diese weiterentwicklung geht weit über
das reine programmieren einer
gewöhnlichen ki hinaus anstatt klaren
regeln zu folgen bekommen maschinen eine
riesenmenge an daten und lernen an
diesem beispiel ganze sich allein was zu
tun ist ein konzept das die quasi noch
intelligenter macht und sie fast
allmächtig wach dass die bläulinge
deswegen nicht nur in der
automobilentwicklung der heiße schickt
sondern beispielsweise auch in der
medizintechnik oder dem militär kommen
wir zurück auf die tests in new jersey
im vergangenen jahr
natürlich wurden die weltweit gefeiert
als sensationeller fortschritt im
bereich der k
doch gleichzeitig gibt dieses ereignis
krw zu denken
niemand wirklich niemand weiß auf
welcher grundlage genau das auto seine
entscheidung trifft entscheidungen
übrigens die nicht ganz unwichtig werden
sondern tatsächlich über leben und tod
entscheiden denn hat die bilderkennung
des autos ein stoppschild tatsächlich
korrekt kategorisiert interpretiert dass
das fahrverhalten der anderen
verkehrsteilnehmer tatsächlich sinnvoll
die antwort ist nicht einmal die
entwickler des autos selbst wissen wie
es tickt und warum es so entscheidet wie
es eben entscheidet und genau dieses
problem ist natürlich auch auf alle
anderen bereiche in dem das learning
eingesetzt wird übertragbar ein fataler
fakt der bislang meist noch
totgeschwiegen wird und zu dessen lösung
es wohl noch ein weiter weg sein wird
dabei gibt es zahlreiche studien und
testergebnisse die alarmierend sind und
die nachteile des die learnings ganz
klar identifizieren
im frühling diesen jahres zum beispiel
zeigt ein us-forscherteam dass die
fehlerquelle bereits in den trainings
daten stecken kann und die zusammenhänge
bei denen es sich jedoch lediglich um
vorurteile handelt unbewusst übernimmt
und als gegeben hin
in diesem konkreten beispiel sollte das
system aus dem größten amerikanischen
computerlinguisten wirtschaft lernen
welche begriffe semantisch
zusammengehören
doch die kn fiel auf die vorhandenen
verzerrung in den trainings daten herein
und assoziierte beispielsweise
männlichen namen klischeehaft mit
begriffen die im zusammenhang mit
bereichen mathematik karriere oder
naturwissenschaften stehen kunst und
familie diese bereiche ordnete die ki
dagegen eher weiblichen namen zu ein
ergebnis das nicht nur ein
eindrucksvolles urteil zum konzepte wie
blue wings fällt sondern dabei auch noch
sehr viel über uns als gesellschaft
verrät und wenn ihr jetzt sagt dass das
ja nur lustige spielerei ist lasst euch
sagen dass das bereits von folgenschwere
konsequenzen für menschen hatte nämlich
für strafgefangene in den usa eine
software mit dem namen compass sollte
den richtern bei der einschätzung
darüber helfen wie hoch das risiko der
einzelnen strafgefangenen seit wieder
rückfällig zu werden
laut einer investigativen recherche der
sonne
zwar einige publica radikal die
hautfarbe der menschen als
entscheidendes merkmal dafür an
kriminelle energie auszuüben
das hatte der algorithmus so aus dem
trainingspartner abgeleitet und ist
natürlich mehr als fatal
und es gibt weitere beispiele aus dem
alltag dafür dass uns künstliche
intelligenz vielleicht schon wer bei zum
verhängnis werden könnte
eine platte deckte beispielsweise auf
dass die australische behörde versteuern
sich auf eine software verlassen hatte
die zu unrecht mehrere tausend mahnung
ausgesprochen hatte
der fehler lag wohl darin dass das
programm unter anderem nicht mit
unterschiedlichen schreibweisen von
namen klargekommen bass hatte also
beispielsweise ein minijobber sein name
im antrag des arbeitgebers anlass
geschrieben als in der steuererklärung
erkannte die software das nicht als
menschlichen fehler sondern nahm an dass
der minijobber zwei verschiedene jobs
hat aber nur von einem das gehalt dem
finanzamt angezeigt hatte diese beiden
face der ki machen wir deutlich dass und
ihre weiterentwicklung vor probleme
stellt die wir schnellstmöglich in den
griff bekommen müssen um weitere
komplikationen zu vermeiden und
schlimmere szenarien im besten fall
schon zu verhindern bevor sie passieren
eine lösung die auf der hand liegt wäre
die entsprechenden faktoren aus dem
trainings daten zu löschen oder wer gar
nicht aufzunehmen
im fall der amerikanischen streffing
könnte der algorithmus die hautfarbe der
gefängnisinsassen natürlich nicht als
entscheidenden faktor aufnimmt wenn er
die fw gar nicht kennen würde
doch obwohl das auf den ersten blick
erst einmal logisch klingt würde ein
löschen einzelner datensätze aus denen
der algorithmus die hautfarbe erkennen
könnte die zerstörung aller daten
bedeuten die erklärung die ki bezieht
sich bei ihren berechnungen nicht auf
die explizite nennung eine eigenschaft
wie beispielsweise der hautfarbe sondern
leitet sich aus anderen daten diese
informationen ab zum beispiel stellte
der algorithmus in diesem konkreten fall
zusammenhänge zwischen dem wohnort und
lebensumständen herbst setzt als ein
forscherteam alle daten die aus ihrer
sicht unter umständen rückschlüsse auf
die hautfarbe zu lassen könnten gelöscht
hatten war die ki dennoch in der lage
die hautfarbe in einem großteil
der fälle herzuleiten warum das äußerst
spannende konzepte wie gewöhnlich nicht
komplett zu verwerfen um alle risiken
auszuschließen dürfte im
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit an einer lösung ihre vision der
computer soll selbst erklären wenn er
eine entscheidung getroffen hat und
welche argumente dahinter stehen in
einem begriff zusammengefasst also
erklärt ware künftig intelligent in
diesem szenario können sie die kiwis ein
menschlicher gesprächspartner mit uns
diskutieren
derjenige der die besseren argumente
vorbringt gewinnt sozusagen heute noch
unvorstellbar doch je mehr vertrauen wir
der ki schenken um so dringender wird
der bedarf an lösung denn fehler im
algorithmus können tödlich entdecken wir
beispielsweise an kriegsflugzeuge
kriegsschiffe und fix fahrzeuge die
ziele automatisch identifizieren
aufgrund dessen hat sich mittlerweile
auch die politik in dieses thema
eingeschaltet
das us-verteidigungsministerium zum
beispiel hat die transparenz von
entscheidungen die auf der basis der kg
getroffen wurden als schlüssel ziel
erklärt und auch in europa und
deutschland hat die politik die brisanz
der lage erkannt die europäische
datenschutz vereinbarung schreibt ab
kommenden jahr vor
das entscheidung die in irgendeiner art
und weise menschen beeinträchtigen
könnten nicht alleine auf der
automatisierten entscheidung von ki war
ihm dürfte zudem soll die bevölkerung
zugriff auf solche verarbeitungsschritte
bekommen politiker diskutieren außerdem
darüber eine art anti
diskriminierungsgesetz für algorithmen
und lebens ofen auch hier wäre dann eine
entscheidung der ki begründungspflicht
ist fraglich sind an diesen überlegungen
viele aspekte
welcher normale mensch und damit meine
ich alle die eben keine it unter
experten sind in der lage solche daten
und angaben zu durchblicken was nützt es
uns also wenn uns diese zugänglich
gemacht werden was genau bedeutet
erklärbar kai der ki werden große
unternehmen wie facebook oder ibm nicht
irgendwelche schlupflöcher finden um
eine herausgabe der daten zu umgehen
senken solche gesetze nicht die
innovative forschungsarbeit ein
dennoch steht fest eine ki die
bedeutende entscheidungen trifft und
diese zudem noch sind
begründen könnte wäre das non-plus-ultra
und eine wahrhaftige sensation und es
gibt tatsächlich forschungsarbeiten die
deutsche ansätze beinhalten ein
forscherteam aus den usa hat eine
methode entwickelt bei der der computer
welche entscheidungen mit einer kurzen
erklärung spickt anwendung hätte diese
idee filus so könnte beispielsweise ein
system dass tumore erkennen soll den
entsprechenden teil des bildes markieren
dass er für die tumor held und seine
hinweise anhängen eine software die mail
von zurück identifizieren soll könnte
die entsprechenden schlüsselwörter
gleich markieren sodass die menschlichen
experten diese nachvollziehen und noch
einmal selbst bewerten können
doch reicht das aus würde so die
erklärung hinter der ki nicht immer
vereinfacht werden und wichtige daten
verloren gehen von einer ki die eine
echte diskussion führt und diese mit
argumenten untermauert die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
jedenfalls noch weit entfernt und selbst
wenn es diese gäbe ist überhaupt jedes
verhalten erklärbar spielen in
entscheidung nicht auch instinkt und das
unterbewusstsein eine rolle könnten wir
der erklärung einer kann überhaupt
komplett folgen oder vertrauen
doch trotz dieser einschränkung wenn wir
uns nun mal dazu entscheiden solche
technologie einzusetzen sollten wir
ebenfalls stark daran interessiert sein
zu verstehen warum und wie sie uns
welche antworten gibt vielen dank an
technology review in zusammenarbeit mit
der redaktion dieser wird die
sensationellen zeitschrift dieses video
entstanden und exklusive mixe zuschauer
habe ich jetzt ein geschenk ihr bekommt
nämlich eine ausgabe gratis wenn er auf
diesen link klickt und hier geht es
weiter mit chat mit einem toten
da geht es um einen jackpot der mithilfe
von ki einen verstorbenen zum leben
erweckt hat braucht wenn es euch
interviewt übrigens auch ein technology
review thema und ansonsten gesang bleibt